hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now the leader of Plymouth city council
is the step down following a row over
the felling of more than 100 trees in
the city center they were cut down last
Tuesday night as part of a plan to
regenerate the area
110 trees were felled before a court
injunction was served campaigners say
that it was done without a proper
consultation and they're calling for the
council to drop their bid to have that
injunction overturned
well I'm joined Now by Hugh James from
the campaign group save the Trees of
armada way he's also chair of the of
environment Plymouth so a very good
afternoon to you thanks for talking to
us the council said that this was all
part of a regeneration project
designed to transform what they say is
this tired and dated City Center rude
they also say that the plan includes
extensive planting of 169 new trees
which would be more resilient to the
urban environment so why has this tree
felling provoked such strength of
feeling there
well this is it's the way as much as
anything that it was done there was a a
consultation process
um which was put out to the public which
wasn't going to happen
um until there was pressure from straw
and other environmental groups including
Plymouth tree partnership and
environment Plymouth and eventually we
had meetings with the um with the
developers we have meetings with the
council with the services director and
at these meetings we were led to believe
that there was a compromise to be made
we were after keeping all the the grade
day and Grade B trees although we may
have lost some of the Grade B trees but
the grade A ones these were part of the
post-war plan that was drawn up and when
our mother way was built in 1952
um this was part of a major
Redevelopment of the entire city after
it was flattened
um during the war and the trees the
chestnut trees particularly which have
become the grade A trees
were the main you can see all the stunts
going down in your pictures to the to
the side of the the green
um those were all grade A the majority
of those were grade A trees I over 40
years old we think they were planted
sort of late 50s
um early 60s and we wanted to keep those
and incorporate the Regeneration scheme
through the middle and this is what we
were understood to be working on a
compromise towards until
um the council decided to under cloak of
Darkness to bring in all the heavy uh
machinery and just tear these trees up
well yes and the reason they say that
the work was carried out at night they
say was for reasons of Public Safety and
impact on the city center given the size
of the of the Machinery the campaign
group did win an injunction to stop the
work how many trees do you think that
saved and what do you want to happen now
um I think I think the estimate is about
um it's different some of the trees were
due to be kept they'd also kept a few
back because uh there were obvious nests
but and so the the ones where they
couldn't see the nests which are now
lying on the ground
um were cut down or torn up
well and what do you want to happen now
very briefly
well we obviously like to keep with
whatever trees we can
um we'd like the planting to go ahead as
quickly as possible
um so the ski I mean there's nothing can
be done about the trees that have been
felt unfortunately all the carbon
capture that was going on with those
trees has now is being released and
what's really sad is to see them lying
on the ground
um and actually starting to Bud and
that's a really sad thing and you think
you know it's silencing all the birds
that were nesting in those trees
um last year now can't so it's it's a
silent Dead Zone and people uh are
appalled I'm I'm standing there very
often
um just looking at the devastation and
talking to people and they can't believe
it so many people in the city had no
idea this was going to happen
um as indeed
um we were all taken by surprise except
the council themselves who actually knew
at six o'clock I mean a notice went out
and the Machinery was already being
moved on to the site so this is not
something that could have been done you
know you don't ring up your local DIY
shop in the morning and get the this
kind of Machinery there in the afternoon
they must have planned this months ahead
and all the all the health and safety
checks and street closure notices
although we never saw any of these
things but they should have been done
um as you said to protect protect people
but whatever time you're going to do it
you uh you still need to order or have
ordered all of that Machinery because
this was this was huge stuff that was
just tearing large trees up out of the
ground and throwing them into large wood
chippers okay this wasn't something
simple Hugh James we appreciate your
time this afternoon thanks so much for
joining us
thank you
well we did ask Plymouth city council
for an interview but they said it would
be inappropriate to comment given the
ongoing legal proceedings surrounding
the injunction
now some of the day's other news stories
now and a rare yet powerful tornado has
hit a Los Angeles suburb ripping off
roofs and sending debris into the sky
one person was injured in the storm in
Montebello which had Winds of up to 110
miles per hour it was the strongest
tornado to hit the area since March
1983.
Argentina are being hit by the worst
drought for 60 years which was ravaged
production of the country's key crops in
its latest weekly report the Buenos
Aires grains exchange says soybean
production was down 44 and corn was down
climate change is causing more frequent
and intense heat waves which speeds up
the drying of the soil
some of the world's largest natural
history museums have joined forces to
build what they describe as a
groundbreaking digital database
featuring all the specimens in their
collections 73 organizations including
the Natural History Museum in London
have contributed to the database which
features more than one billion objects
the aim is to help scientists and policy
makers find solutions to issues such as
climate change and biodiversity loss
now Colombia the Democratic Republic of
Congo and Ecuador have taken the lead in
what the UN is describing as the largest
ever initiative to restore degraded
rivers lakes and wetlands the freshwater
challenge has been launched at the Water
conference which is taking place in New
York the UN says a third of the world's
wetlands have been lost over the last 50
years and the aim is to bring back a 200
000 miles of rivers and enough Wetlands
to fill an area the size of India by
2030. well I'm joined Now by Claire
seaward whose Global campaigns director
at Water Aid um Cliffy thanks for
talking to us today just how important
is this initiative what difference could
this freshwater challenge make to to
people but also to habitats to Nature
uh thank you for having me it's a really
exciting initiative as part of uh the
world's biggest water conference for 45
years and this will obviously have a
really important impact for biodiversity
but as you said
um people experiencing climate change
right now through either too much or too
little water and Water Aid has actually
come to this issue from a really
different place but to the same end
because that we absolutely need Wetlands
to be in places of a key way of managing
water now if we get it right what it
means is that we can help protect
um nature and and people from things
like flooding and the damage of flooding
it can also help to recharge water under
the ground which is being depleted in
parts of the world such as Pakistan and
India and Bangladesh and it's a really
important source of water supply for
animals but also people during drought
and that's how we get it right if we get
this wrong not only the depletion of the
nature but also to see disease outbreaks
for people and we're seeing right now
our cholera outbreak in 26 countries
with one billion people at risk because
of contaminated water so the stakes are
high and this investment is critical for
Stakes are high but the project is very
ambitious how do you go about turning
things around in these countries
first of all I think we're seeing if
there's a real need for strong
government leadership and it's great we
have country governments that are
stepping up on this right now
um one of the things that water Aid is
really Keen to see is that we're
bringing together the planning for water
for multiple uses water for people water
for nature water for business use like
Agriculture and industry it's only by
all of those groups coming together and
actually in proper planning and proper
government leadership that we're
actually going to see the change we want
to see now Water Aid is doing this in
some of the countries where we're
working already we're actually bringing
together
um companies in countries uh like
Nigeria and like Mozambique to actually
try and re-re replenish waterways such
as Wetlands but for multiple uses so for
example in Lagos State Nigeria we're
actually working on something called
sponge cities which is how do you
actually create water catchments to
capture flooding to prevent uh damage to
ecosystems and to cities
we're also doing this maputo which is on
the front line of things like Cyclone
Freddy right now and actually restoring
mangroves um which can actually protect
people from flooding and protect
wetlands and and nature and this is
really why I bring it together okay a
fascinating subject I wish we had longer
to discuss it but we are out of time a
classic thanks so much for joining us
today
thank you and that's all from us for
today thanks for watching